14:45 and the war with France isn't
going too well it was also in this year
that England's Henry the sixth married
Margaret of Anjou the niece of the
French King Charles the seventh to
secure the marriage he secretly offered
to give up the territory of Maine the
marriage also got Henry a truce but the
peace wouldn't last forever at home
henry's court was factional and his laws
disagreed on many things mostly on
whether or not to continue the war with
France in the Kings faction which wanted
peace was William dela Powell the Earl
of Suffolk and Edmund Beaufort the Earl
of Somerset opposing them was Humphrey
the Duke of Gloucester and Richard of
York who in a stunning twist of events
was the Duke of York due to political
maneuvers York's military command in
France wasn't renewed and he was
replaced by Somerset who was now a Duke
soon after York's return it became
public that Henry had promised Maine
away and people were quite upset about
it
Gloucester in particular was angry about
this and openly spoke out against the
Kings actions as a result Henry had him
tried for treason in 1447 and during his
arrest he died so Gloucester was Henry's
uncle and since Henry had no children
was thus the heir to the throne since
Gloucester was now dead the next in line
was now the Duke of York to get York out
of the picture Henry had him sent to
Ireland Henry was becoming increasingly
unpopular and many Nobles blamed Suffolk
Parliament wanted him tried a traitor
but instead Henry exiled him for five
years
Suffolk left for France but he was
intercepted on the way and beheaded to
make matters worse a popular revolt
broke out in 1450 led by a man called
either John or Jack Cade Kate's
rebellion was against the corruption of
the nobles and Kate demanded perform
this rebellion was initially successful
taking London but soon descended into
looting and violence before Kate was
killed in the rebellion crushed in the
same year Somerset surrendered Norman
Dean instead of being punished was
rewarded York upon hearing this decided
that he would return to England raise an
army and get rid of the Kings terrible
advisers which he did two sides had now
formed the Lancastrians led by Somerset
and Queen Margaret who backed the king
and the Yorkists led by Richard of York
tensions remained high for the next
couple of years and in 1452 York was
summoned to meet the king which he
believed was a trap heeeeelp refused to
go and did the only thing he could rebel
by mobilizing an army the King mobilized
in response and both looked poised for
battle
however they stood down York and his
supporters were pardoned who many of
York's opponents were dismissed from
power the next year 1453 was a big year
in English history the early months bore
good news for Henry Gascony was secured
in Queen Margaret became
pregnant this good news wouldn't last
though since the French would bethe
conquer Gascony thus winning the Hundred
Years War to make matters more
complicated there was a feud brewing
between two powerful northern families
the Percy's headed by the Earl of
Northumberland and the Neville's headed
by the Earl of Warwick Somerset sided
with Northumberland and as a result
warrick allied with York it was at this
point that Henry had a mental breakdown
leaving Margaret in charge in October
Margaret gave birth to a son Prince
Edward meaning that York was no longer
the heir to the throne Henry showed no
signs of getting better and in 1454
Regency was established the two factions
fight for power and Parliament gave the
Regency to York York immediately
stripped Somerset of his offices and
sent margaret away from court this
period is known as the first
Protectorate in York was actually a good
region undertaking much needed reform
the king however made a recovery in
later 1454 and soon after removed York
as region and brought Somerset back with
the Lancastrian faction back in control
the Yorkist feared a backlash and so
rebellion York was summoned to the king
declined and marched his army south
where he was reinforced by Warwick King
Henry raised an army as well and the two
meta st. Albans negotiations broke down
between the two sides because at this
point everyone hated each other and so
battle commenced beginning the Wars of
the Roses the Battle of st. Albans was
the Yorkist victory which saw Somerset
killed and King Henry captured York was
appointed as the constable of England ie
he was in charge and Henry soon after
became ill again this began the second
Protectorate which lasted until 1456
when Henry recovered and again dismissed
York the peace was uneasy and so Henry
made sure to give rewards to both
factions where it was given the
captaincy of Calais but mostly engaged
in piracy tensions remained high and in
1458 henry tried to reconcile both sides
and what was dubbed the love day where
both sides promised to calm down so both
sides now friends forever went back to
immediately plotting each other's
downfalls Warwick was recalled to London
to answer for his piracy and upon his
return he got into a fight
Warwick accused the Queen of attempting
to kill him in the Queen ordered that
Warwick be arrested worked fled to
Calais and refused to return both sides
began to mobilize their armies because
at this point why not fighting broke out
in 1459 with initial York his success
but later in the same year York and
Henry's armies met at Ludford Bridge the
Yorkists were massively outnumbered and
their men didn't want to fight the king
so the Orcas did the only thing they
could run away soon after this a
parliament was called known as the
Parliament of the Devils which condemned
the Yorkists as traitors and took their
land in 1460 the
his struck back and work accompanied by
York's son Edward and an army landed
here before marching on London men in
the South were supporters of the
Yorkists the London open its gates to
them without resistance not long
afterwards Warrick led an army nor firm
at the Lancastrian army at Northampton
the Battle of Northampton was a major
Yorkist victory and resulted in the king
being captured again the Yorkists were
now firmly in control and so York found
it safe to return the reason for his
return this time was not to remove the
Kings favorites from court but to assert
his own claim to the throne these pretty
much appalled everyone even his allies a
settlement was eventually reached that
Henry would remain King and York would
be named his heir Queen Margaret was
unhappy that her son had been
dispossessed and so sought help from the
Scots who gave her an army York marched
north to confront them but instead of
holding up in a castle and awaiting
reinforcements he met the Lancastrians
in battle here at Wakefield Wakefield
was a Lancastrian victory in a major
setback for York's ambitions since he
was killed there the claim to the throne
now lay with York's eldest son Edward
who is intent on pursuing it the Yorkist
and Lancastrian clashed several times in
early 1461 Edward won a battle here of
Mortimer's cross which saw him capture
one of King Henry's favorites Owen Tudor
who Edward promptly executed Warwick was
defeated at the Second Battle of st.
Albans by Margaret's army and after this
emery the sick was found sitting under a
tree unharmed Margaret didn't capitalize
on her victory and stayed away from
London mainly because the people there
weren't too happy with the idea of an
army of Scots led by a French Queen
entering the city
Edward was able to enter the city dome
was warmly welcomed soon after this the
Yorkists and the people of London asked
him to take the throne which he did
becoming King yet with the fourth Edward
took an army and marched north
determined to secure his throne and he
met the Lancastrians here at Alton the
Battle of tauten was fought between 40
and 50 thousand men with about 30,000
being killed and is the bloodiest battle
ever fought on English soil
Edward was victorious and survived Henry
and Margaret fled to Scotland
Edward's early reign was fairly
uneventful but was plagued by the
question of his Lords loyalties in 1464
Lancastrian rebels were defeated at the
Battle of Hexham and things started
looking better for Edward Edward did
something that Kings aren't supposed to
do marry for love which is what he did
when he tied the knot in secret with a
lady called Elizabeth Woodville Kings
were supposed to marry for financial or
political reasons which is why Warwick
was negotiating for Edward to marry a
relative of the French King horik looked
a bit of an idiot when Edward told him
in their relationship soured as the king
came more independent Henry at this
point had been hiding in the north of
England trying to gather support he did
this until 1465 when he was captured and
brought to the Tower of London
by this point Warwick was essentially
plotting against the king who had chosen
the Woodville's over him and prevented
marriages between their families
that was until Warwick did it anyway
marrying his daughter to Edwards brother
George the Duke of Clarence who wanted
the throne a rebellion led by one of
Warwick's men broke out in 1469 the
rebel army met the kings at the Battle
of edge coat and the rebels were
victorious
Edward was taken prisoner shortly
afterwards and Warwick knowing he
couldn't depose the King attempted to
rule through him this state of affairs
didn't last and it wasn't long before
the nobility of England had started to
rally against him Warwick was forced to
release Edward in 1469 but Edward made
no attempt to punish Warwick or
retaliate Warwick did lose his influence
though and there was only one person who
could help him get some of it back Henry
the sixth some men loyal to Warwick
started a rebellion it was crushed
Warwick was implicated and promptly ran
away to seek the aid of the French king
who by the way was called Louie
waraqa Margaret progression he came to
an agreement and Warwick along with the
French army landed in England in 1470
many of Edwards Lord's flock to the
Lancastrians and so Edward had one
honourable option run away the
Lancastrians then entered London and
freed King Henry from the Tower of
London and he was declared king again
but make no mistake Warwick was in
charge he was extremely unpopular though
since the Lancastrians didn't trust him
due to his toppling of Henry in the
Yorkist despised him because of his
toppling of Edward who was at this point
in Burgundy France with the help of
Henry invaded Burgundy and so it's Duke
gave Edward a bunch of money to invade
England Edward did this happily and
landed in Yorkshire in early 1471 and
his invasion culminated in two important
battles the first was the Battle of
Barnet a york his victory in which
Warwick was killed the second one was
the Battle of Tewkesbury another Yorkist
victory which importantly included the
death of Henry's son Prince Edward and
the capture of Margaret Edward the
fourth soon after entered London and it
wasn't long before Henry the sixth died
probably from a case of the murders
Edward's throne was now secure and the
Lancastrians were essentially destroyed
the next decade of Edwards reign was
uneventful but importantly he did bring
back stability as well as strengthening
the law he became sick and died in 1483
and was succeeded by his son the twelve
year old Edward v
Edward wasn't old enough to rule on his
own and so his uncle Richard the Duke of
Gloucester was appointed as Lord
Protector to govern for him a struggle
broke out between Richard in the wood
crossed a woman with the help of some
clergymen had ed with v decried as
illegitimate making him the heir Edward
v who was confined to the Tower of
London with his younger brother was
deposed after three months and Richard
was crowned Richard the third it wasn't
long into Richards reign when a
significant rebellion broke out led by
the Duke of Buckingham and Henry Tudor
Richard defeated Buckingham since Henry
who is in Brittany was prevented from
reinforcing henry ended up in paris
where he was given an army to invade
which he did in 1485 henry marched
inland a met Richard's larger army at
the Battle of Bosworth Field it was here
that Richard was killed ending the
Yorkist dynasty in allowing Henry Tudor
the half nephew of Henry the sixth to
take the throne henry was crowned henry
the seventh for married the daughter of
Edward the fourth thus uniting the
claims of both houses of Lancaster and
York into that of one house the House of
Tudor
I hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching there are some
book recommendations in the description
below if you'd like to know more
you